hey everyone how's it going hope you are
well my name's miyuko and welcome back
to my channel where we talk about tech
career and life so today i wanted to
talk about how i organize my life
one of the things that i realized which
is a really core part of like adult life
like after graduating college and
working for a little bit
is that there's a lot of things to keep
track of and because i have a memory of
a little bumblebee
i need ways to keep track of everything
that's going on
not to mention my anxiety always makes
me worried and like scared of everything
all the time
and so instead of like trying to hold on
to everything to
try to keep my life together one of the
things that i do
is break down big scary things into
small tasks and then plan accordingly
by using my organizational tools call me
leslie knope or amy santiago but i think
that staying
organized keeping track of things is a
great way to just feel like you've got
your life together
especially in 2020 when it feels like
everything in the world is going wrong
and on top of that you also have to stay
on top of your own stuff just to
stay afloat and feel like you have some
semblance of control of your life
because i know that if i sit down
and spend like an hour just like
figuring out
my stuff for a little bit then i
definitely feel
a lot more at peace and i know exactly
what i need to
do in order to like move forward in life
and i've got like a good
organizational system right now for how
to organize my life
so i wanted to share that with you today
in case any of you find that helpful or
inspirational or motivational or maybe
you're just watching it for
entertainment i don't know
either way i'm glad you're here click
subscribe also maybe i'm not as intense
as leslie knope and amy santiago because
i don't have like one-inch binders for
everything
because i have a mix of like digital
organizational systems along with analog
and binders just don't really make it
into the mix but i'm gonna tell you
about what i do use so you'll notice
that a lot of my organizational tools
are about simplifying my life
making sure that i'm spending the right
time on the right amount of things
and that can be applied to a lot of
things in my life as well as how i read
which brings me to the sponsor of
today's video blinkist
blinkist is an app that allows you to
just get the best insights from over 3
000 non-fiction books
in less than 15 minutes and if that
doesn't sound like simplifying your life
then i don't know what is
you can either read or listen to these
books podcast style and also access them
offline it's a really easy app to use
and there's a ton of recommendations and
new blanks are being added every day
i've always loved the insights that
malcolm gladwell shares in his books but
his books are pretty dense and i have a
really hard time getting through them
so i really enjoyed listening to talking
to strangers
one of his recent books about how we
don't really know
much about strangers and how we always
make the wrong assumption about them
so the first 100 people to go to
blinkist.com
slash hello mayuko will get seven days
to try out the app for completely free
with unlimited access
you can cancel at any time during that
period but if you want to continue you
get 25
off the full membership thank you to
blinkist for sponsoring today's video
and now let's get back into organizing
so right now in my life i'm juggling
being a full-time content creator
being a software engineer and developing
apps on the side
as well as just like life adult things
that i'm trying to keep track of so i
have a really hard time just keeping all
that stuff
inside my brain especially when i was
like a full-time software developer and
there's just so many
details to remember in software
development whether that be
remembering how something works or
remembering that i have to fix this
thing later on
and so i realized early on that writing
things down
offloading the things that are in my
brain onto something else
is a great is a great great way to not
only remember
things but also keep track of all the
tasks that i have to do
when i write things down my brain is
just like way more freed up
with space and there's more computing
power so that i can spend it on more
important things than grasping onto
these little bundles of information
and yes sometimes that computing power
goes to like
playing games or watching tv but at
least i'm not like
exhausted and it's like i have a choice
on how to spend
my brain power instead of being like so
exhausted all the time
about remembering things and then like
feeling guilty when i don't remember
things that people counted on me for
because that's one of the worst feelings
like letting other people down
and i just like don't want to count on
my brain because it's not exactly the
most like
dependable memory source there's way
better systems out there to remember
these things so that i
can be counted on and people can trust
me to get things done so yeah that's
kind of the ethos around like all of my
organizational systems it's just a lot
about
unloading the stuff that's in here into
something that's written
and generally speaking i always try to
see like two or three weeks ahead
because
i hate the feeling of like a week coming
and then realizing like oh my god i
uploaded everything until this point and
now i'm overwhelmed and now i can't meet
all these deadlines so having like a two
or three week buffer allows me to
kind of move things around allows me to
be more flexible and
i can kind of like start certain
processes in my brain ahead of time
in case there are things that need to be
done like three weeks from now
anyway so that was like a long setup for
like why i think this stuff is important
and how i came to like these systems
but let's get started so first we're
going to talk about my calendar
i've always used a calendar it's a great
way for me to keep track of deadlines
and events
and meetings and stuff historically i've
used the apple calendar
as well as google calendar but recently
i've been using readle's calendar app
i have the calendar app both on my mac
and my iphone
on my mac i use the calendar that's
available through their email client
called spark and then on my phone i have
their calendar app so the reason why i
really like using their calendar app
over
others is that i really like their
weekly view i feel like their ui for
being able to glance at your week ahead
is better than other apps out there and
so i've been using this for many many
months now and it's been really great
on mac the calendar is integrated with
the email client directly which is great
because i use the two together all the
time the calendar app just lets me do
all the things that i want invite people
schedule things
create video conferencing things i have
a calendar just for my work stuff
as well as a calendar for my personal
stuff and a shared calendar between me
and my husband scott
for any shared events that we have so
next up is project management tools
so this is where i keep track of all of
my projects and tasks
and mainly i've been using two apps the
first one is click up
i really needed an app to help me track
all the videos that i have planned
as well as all the tasks related to
video creation
and content creation i like that i can
add a lot of custom fields and link to
tasks together and have many different
lists and boards too
generally it's been really flexible for
me and it works for many different use
cases
both for content creation and also
software development i'd actually only
heard about click up like a month or two
ago
i've used asana and monday.com but i
liked that click up had all the features
and flexibility that i wanted
and at a good price for a one person
team and so this is actually where like
the bulk of my
tasks and stuff go and i've been kind of
using it in a sprint style way so
every week i have a chunk of tasks that
i have to work on
and i have many sprints planned out
ahead of time and that way i can see for
any given week what's the workload like
what am i going to be doing that week
and
if i see that one sprint like many weeks
in the future has too many things then i
can shuffle things around
the other project management tool that i
use is trello so i feel like trello is
such a staple in the software
development communities
i've used it in a lot of software
projects before and so i always use the
same setup for each board that i create
i usually create a
this week column or to-do column for
things that are on deck that i need to
do right now
and then i have an in-progress column to
also see what i'm working on currently
i have a done column to specify things
that are finished as well as a backlog
column for all of the other tasks that
maybe aren't really important right now
but need to get done eventually and the
ability to use
labels and assign things to tasks makes
it a really simple and effective project
management tool right now i'm using
trello for my personal project where i'm
developing an ios app on the side
as well as some team projects where i'm
just working on some things with other
folks
it is quite a simple app it's not quite
as beefy in the future set
compared to other tools out there but
for really simple projects that i'm
working on it works really great
and so i really like using the
combination of the two click up allows
me to
organize my own tasks but if i needed to
do more with it then i kind of need to
pay more and i don't really want to get
there
and so for all of the things that don't
need that feature set
being able to use trello and share with
friends and keep track of other projects
that are a little bit simple
has been a really good system for me so
next up is
notes so i think of notes as like a
catch-all not only do i write down
information and ideas and things that
i've learned
but sometimes i do use it as like a
calendar sometimes i use it as a project
management
tool it's kind of just like if i need
something quick and i don't want to open
up a browser i'm not near my computer or
i just need to write something down
because i might forget my notebook is
where it goes
and so for this one i also use a combo
of tools one
is my notebook i shared this in my most
recent video my back to school
essentials
but having something analog that i can
write into with a pen
uh is sometimes just like the best
format for me to write in
and especially because you can kind of
draw and write anything that you want
without needing to adhere to any lines
or rules of the notebook
sometimes i find that it's the best way
for me to get my thoughts onto paper and
so yeah i have like diary entries in
there i've got to do lists in there i've
got dates i've got meeting notes
it's just got a lot of things before i
used to try to use my notebook is like
this is the one thing that i'm gonna use
my notebook for but i ended up not using
it because i set
such rigid rules for myself on how to
use my notebook that i got scared to use
it and so now i kind of have this like
anything goes kind of policy
which has made my notebook a lot more
useful to me and i use it a lot more now
and so on the digital side of the
equation i use dropbox paper now i
love using dropbox paper dropbox paper
is like one of my favorite products
within the last five years
so dropbox paper is just like a
collaborative document editing tool
just like google documents or anything
else out there
but it is just so easy to use the
formatting is similar to what you could
do using markdown you can create lists
you can create calendars you can assign
tasks to people
it's really easy to create headers and
just a really nice long document of
information
i do a lot of my like video writing and
script writing in there
and then also if i just need to like
dump information from my brain onto
something i
type faster than i can actually write
and so dropbox paper is usually where
i'll go
it's also really easy to link things
it's also easy to
share a dropbox paper with anybody it's
just like the
easiest and also prettiest tool to use
and so it's like been a major
ad to my whole like productivity
organizational workflow so the last
thing that i use
for how i organize my life is siri i
really like to use siri over other voice
assisted apps out there because i really
trust apple with my information because
they make privacy and safety like a
number one rule when creating their
products
not that i'm using it for super like
sensitive things or anything like that
but
i do think that privacy and safety is
something that's really important and
we're
noticing that it's increasingly so
especially in 2020
and so i really admire and love the fact
that apple has taken such a stance
against that
anyway this is now just me an ios
developer talking about how much you
love apple products and i know they can
be annoying so i'm gonna stop now
anyways i use siri mostly for reminders
i wear an apple watch and i also have my
phone and so being able to say like
hey siri remind me to make an
appointment tomorrow or something like
that really quickly when it's on my mind
allows me to remember certain things
because it is easier to like talk to
siri than it is to like open up an app
type it in because i can get distracted
in so many ways before i even get to the
app if i see like notifications from
different apps and stuff
so yeah that's been really cool again
this is all kind of a product of me
having like a terrible memory this is
why i didn't major in biology or become
a doctor or anything because
that stuff is way too hard so i hope you
like this video let me know what kind of
organizational tips and systems and apps
that you use
in the description box no not in the
description box in the comments you
can't run the description box
let me know what are things that you
like to use to organize your life in the
comment section down below and if you
like this video then
subscribe check out all the rest of my
videos on my channel i come out with
videos weekly about various topics about
me and my life
in tech and career and whatever i feel
like making
so come join the fam so that's it and
i'll see you next time
hope you have a great day wherever you
are bye